we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to David P here is a
caller
calling in about whether I will be
fleeing the Northeast to Florida
David it's Alan from Jersey I just heard
you say that you are in fact moving to
Florida you are going to move into the
village with Pat and some of the
Dolphins and ride around the golf carts
and yell out white power I can't believe
that you will be a snowbird because
you're missing the best part of the East
Coast winter is the best season yeah
listen uh I am not moving to Florida as
of this time if I did move to Florida on
a part of full-time basis I would not
live at The Villages I would not shout
white power and I probably would not
swim with the dolphins but no in all
seriousness I know winter spring summer
the changes the snow the Foley the
entire I get it um I've done it for
decades and I can still get winter if
I'm in Florida January and February
right we still have winter in December
and to some degree March okay so I am
thinking about
for the purpose is of spending time
outdoors and Beach and all these
different things Mental Health
should I become a snowbird many decades
sooner than many people do but no
decisions have been made as of this time
we have a great bonus show on the bonus
show we will talk about remote work
costing Manhattan more than 12 billion
dollars a year we will talk about the
CDC reporting that teen girls are in an
extreme wave of sadness and violence
what is causing it what can and should
be done and we will also talk about
teacher salaries increasingly becoming a
bipartisan cause low pay is being agreed
upon as a major crisis in education all
of those stories and more today not
tomorrow not some other day in the
future today on the bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com I look forward to
seeing you there